the beaming new father wanted to
personally announce the news that they
welcomed a baby son instant world I'm
very excited to announce that Megan and
myself have a baby boy early this
morning a very healthy boy mother and
baby are doing incredibly well it's been
the most amazing experience I can ever
possibly imagine how any woman does what
they do is beyond comprehension but
we're both absolutely thrilled and so
grateful to all the love and support for
everybody out there I'm so incredibly
proud of my wife and as every father and
parent we'd ever say you know you're
your babies absolutely amazing but this
little thing is the official
announcement had come through their
Instagram accounts confirming their
child had been born in the early hours
of the morning weighing 7 pounds and 3
ounces and that mum and baby were both
healthy and well the new arrival for
this modern royal couple was also marked
in the traditional way with an easel
saying the Queen and the rest of the
family were delighted ever since they
revealed in Australia in October that
they were expecting their first child
the anticipation has built around this
couple the reality of another royal baby
ramping up the interest in Megan to
another level but the cameras been out
of every engagement watching that
growing thumb
I feel the embryonic kicking of feminism
for many this still marks another
significant moment for the monarchy even
though their son is 7th in line to the
throne I won't necessarily be a prince
because this boy is a great grandchild
of the sovereign he won't be a royal
highness but according to peerage law he
will take the second title of his father
who is of course Duke of Sussex and that
is Earl of Dumbarton but of course we
haven't yet been told precisely what the
parents want
to be called and that will probably be
announced by the palace quite soon as
the couple spent time at Frogmore
cottage with Megan's mum Doria on hand
to help out her estranged father Thomas
Markov released his own message about
the baby
saying I'm proud that my new grandson is
born into the British royal family and
I'm sure he will grow up to serve the
crown and the people of Britain with
grace dignity and honor god bless the
child and I wish him health and
happiness and my congratulations to my
lovely daughter Duchess Megan and Prince
Harry and God Save the Queen the
international interest around their
first child was always going to be huge
and from the very first moment they have
worked incredibly hard to control every
detail that has been released about
their new son it also means that we're
going to have to wait at least a couple
of days before we finally see pictures
of them as a family of three now the
wait for their new arrival is over
marking the start of a life-changing new
chapter this new mum and dad Rhiannon
Mills Sky News in Windsor